The known part of life is absolutely dull
and boring.
Nobody wants to watch a movie of someone's
life that goes like this: John was born.
He went to school.
Then he went to college.
Then he met a girl in college.
Then he got married.
Then they had kids.
Then he had a good job.
The he got fired from his good job.
Then he got a second good job.
The he got fired from his second good job.
Then he got a third good job.
Then it was okay.
They bought a house.
They lived there, the kids met somebody.
They got married.
They became grandparents, they were good grandparents.
They died, 192 people showed up at their funeral.
That's it, the end.
No one buys that book.
Who the hell wants to read that book?
Except for the people that are related to
him.
I think every single one of us wants to have
the story of the person that's born, they
go through a shit load of difficulties, life
is difficult, it's annoying, insecurities,
fear, heavy-duty change, constant challenges,
marital, health, family, finance, all this
type of crap and then all of a sudden they're
going through a bunch of different struggles
and then they figure it out and then this
idea comes to their mind and things change
and they start taking it and five other people
decide to join them, and then the enemy comes
and one of their competitors tries to put
them out of business, and they go against
the enemy and it becomes a heavy weight fight.
The become the underdogs.
Nobody expected them to do anything and then
all of a sudden, they win, and they take that
money and create libraries and take it and
start other businesses, and create 2800 jobs
and make a difference around the world and
BOOM!
All of a sudden this is what happens.
People want to know that story.
And I think everybody wants to live that story.
And if they didn't want to live that story,
Hollywood would never do good.
Why does Hollywood do good?
Because for two hours you and I can sit in
a movie theater and for those two hours, we're
absolutely lost.
It's as if we're high on drugs, because for
two hours we think we are the Wolf of Wall
Street.
We think for two hours we're Braveheart.
We think we are the gladiator.
We think we're Marcus Aurelius.
We think we're Rocky.
And then we come out in tears.
And then we forget about it.
But a few people come out and say, "I'm not
just going to watch a movie named Rocky.
I'm going to go be the Rocky in my life.
I think that's really want it comes down to.